[Musique]
invité ce matin c'est vous antoine
wauters bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
vous êtes écrivain poète vous êtes aussi
scénariste votre dernier ouvrage c'est
le musée des contradictions c'est un
recueil de douze discours engagé qui
dépasse notre monde d'aujourd'hui qui a
obtenu notamment le goncourt de la
nouvelle je crois mais celui qui nous
intéresse ce matin c'est celui qu'on
voit à l'image dans ce moment il a
marqué la critique il est sorti l'an
dernier il a reçu plusieurs prix
notamment le prix inter il ya quelques
jours seulement une nouvelle poétique
c'est une histoire composée en vers
libres autrement dit qui respecte pas
les codes pas forcément des rimes ou des
alexandrins
ça s'appelle donc marbre de la montée
des eaux est aux éditions verdier et en
gros c'est un livre qui décrit en
quelque sorte la société syrienne soit
fait à la chaîne al assad puis sous
bachar en passant pas par des ch et à
travers le destin d'un homme c'est un
vieux pot est un ancien professeur tout
se passe autour du lac al assad dans la
province de jaca c'est un lac centrale
dans le récit on va peut-être le voir
sur sur une carte on le verra un petit
peu en images on a quelques archives de
cela qu al assad dans la province de
jaca pourquoi est ce que vous l'avez
choisie c'est quoi votre rapport à la
syrie c'est un amour de c'est une
affection s'éteint c'est un pays où je
n'ai pas eu la chance de voyager
malheureusement j'ai pu faire un voyage
assez long au liban qui m'a terriblement
marqué et ça fait en gros une dizaine
d'années je m'intéresse vraiment à ce
qui se passe dans cette partie du monde
ce qui fait que je me suis
passionné ou intéressés à ce sujet là
c'est que je me suis rendu compte autour
de 2015 quand j'ai commencé à écrire le
livre que ce que j'en apprenais ce que
gens découvraient au travers des médias
me semble est lacunaire et qui est
surtout que ça me permettait pas de
ressentir réellement ce qui se passait
là bas je crois que j'ai eu un mouvement
de recul en entendant ce qui se passe
est quotidiennement là bas
cette espèce d'information à flux tendu
qui était pour moi violente à recevoir
et surtout qui ne me permet pas n'était
pas d'aller plus loin dans la
compréhension de ce qui se passe du
conflit et au départ l'idée n'était pas
d'écrire un livre mais bien d'essayer de
me donner les moyens de comprendre et de
regarder cette réalité là droit dans les
yeux
sans détourner le regard c'était ça
l'idée donc vous avez beaucoup lu puis
vous êtes beaucoup aspect documentaire
n'a réalisateur syrien autour du barrage
absolument c'est vrai que c'est le film
qui s'appelle déluge aux pays du bassin
de omar amiralay réalisateur syrien qui
est décédé en 2011 qui m'a donné l'idée
d'écrire ce récit puisqu'on y voit déjà
la figure d'un vieil homme sur une
barque et qui dit que sous le plancher
de la barque se trouve son village sa
maison et s'en passer englouti et je me
suis dit que c'était une belle manière
d'essayer de raconter l'histoire de la
syrie fait replonger un vieil homme
littéralement dans les eaux du souvenir
et dans dans sa propre mémoire qui la
mémoire aussi d'un pays dont celle
heureux de ce livre appelle mahmoud avec
lui on va naviguer sur ce lac n'est donc
de la création de ce barrage soit fès al
assad est sous cette barque donc il ya
des dizaines de mètres dos et puis à son
ancien village et ses souvenirs son
ancienne vie entre ces deux périodes il
régimes totalitaires d'hafez al assad
l'arrivée au pouvoir de bachar avec
espoir puis ensuite la dictature
sanguinaire arrive des choses pourquoi
avoir choisi de retracer ces périodes à
travers les drames d'un seul homme
c'était c'est une question presque de ce
si j'avais été cinéaste la question se
serait posé peut-être plus plus plus
frontalement encore c'est à dire que
qu'est ce qu'on montre d'un pays en
guerre et un cinéaste aurait pu filmer
la série sous toutes ses dimensions
ça veut dire faire un film très
horizontale qui montraient tout ce qui
se passe sur la préface du territoire et
moi j'ai pensé que s'agissant d'un texte
qui parle aussi de la mémoire et de ce
qu'on ne voit plus d'un pays parce que
la guerre est un engloutissement la
guerre détruit toute trace du passé qui
trouvait que c'était intéressant de me
focaliser justement un endroit très
particulier c'est ce lac qui est le
produit de la création du barrage de tap
cas et il se trouve qu'effectivement
2017 c'est dèche qui tenait ce lieu ce
barrage et il y avait un risque de
d'inondations inondations massives est
majeure et je me suis dit c'est quand
même extraordinaire que ce pays et qui
est déjà depuis depuis toujours en fait
sous le joug d'une dictature
et en plus ce risque d'un déluge si le
barrage venait à céder à rompre et j'ai
pensé qu'en fait l'histoire de la syrie
était contenu dans la seule image de ce
lac qui engloutit des populations l'idée
était très simple je suis parti de là
pour essayer de comprendre la façon dont
vous l'avez construit est ce que vous
pourriez s'il vous plaît nous en lire un
extrait ça vous ennuie maps je sais que
c'est vraiment parlant de la façon dont
dont vous avez construit le récit dans
ce livre c'est un petit passage
donc mahmoud et étant est en train de
descendre dans les eaux du lac il dit
je sauve un papillon de la noyade mais
doit dans les algues comme d'autres
algues de faim poisson puis je ferme les
yeux et je descends descends jusqu'à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus aucun bruit sauf
celui de l'eau contre mon coeur
l'eau qui me respirer me console comme
seul le peut une mère
nageant je redeviens l'enfant mahmoud
des prairies j'entends mounir hurlait
sur moi qui suis le vent parmi les bêtes
de son troupeau et qu ils essaiment sur
le sentier je sent le parfum de maman
qui est une force virevoltante un vrai
buisson ardent mais dont les nerfs aussi
sont brûlants et ardent vieillir c'est
devenir l'enfant que plus personne ne
voit l'enfant dont on dit qu'il a les
cheveux gris dont on attend des choses
promesses gloire et accomplissements
alors que tout ce qu'ils souhaitent
c'est resté à jouer avec son mat avec
son bâton en regardant tomber la pluie
les mains couvertes de boue vierge de
parole et de tout clinquant je suis
vieux sarah de mon coeur parce que j'ai
7 ans tous les jours depuis sept
décennies mais que plus personne ne le
voit ça c'est mon âge il plonge il n'a
pas vraiment envie de remonter c'est ça
et d'affronter la réalité c'est ça parce
qu'elle est terrible pour lui
il plonge pour retrouver ses souvenirs
ses enfants brahim salim nazif et ces
femmes les la sarre à ses parents aussi
c'est son quotidien est plutôt que
d'abandonner face au drame ou au nombre
d'heures qu'il a connu au dureté de
cette époque de la dictature de trois
ans de torture ans en prison il continue
à s'accrocher à la vie c'est le cas de
beaucoup deux syriens on parle beaucoup
de résilience en ce moment c'est un peu
le terme à la mode
qu'est ce qui fait que cet homme
continue de s'accrocher à la ville qui a
tout perdu à la fois il continue et ne
continue pas c'est parce que ce que vous
disiez très juste c'est que quand il
plonge il est dans un rapport très
paradoxal à tout ça est ce que
réellement c'est peut-être une fuite
aussi un simplement se laisser engloutir
comme ça ou retrouver un temps qu'ils
étaient plus heureux et il a un rapport
particulier au combat ses enfants sont
partis se battre ses enfants sont partis
manifester bachar manifester et lui
comme beaucoup de poètes syrien mais ça
réellement aujourd'hui en syrie il ya eu
beaucoup d'écrivains de poètes syrien
qui ont pris la parole en disant
attention au moment des printemps arabes
il est tout à fait légitime de
rechercher cette liberté mais n'oubliez
pas qui vous avez en face de 20 bachar
on sait ce qu'il est capable de faire et
donc qui a eu comme ça des prises de
parole qui disaient oui on comprend
cette jeunesse qui veut vivre qui veut
vivre librement et en même temps faites
attention parce que ce qui se joue et
est compliquée dangereux et on sait on
sait de quoi bachar est capable c'est le
propos du livre c'est en gros un érudit
un intellectuel mais qui prend pas
position qui est pas un véritable
opposant mais qui est comme beaucoup de
syriens qui lie qui s'intéressent au
monde qui les entoure est ce qu'il en
reste encore beaucoup d des gens comme
ça en syrie qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce
qu'on en sait de cette culture syrienne
qui était riche alors et en fait on
danse et on en sait très peu et c'est ça
qui est ça qui moi m'a même intéressé ma
concernés dans l'écriture de ce livre en
fait tous les 7 1 contre récit ce texte
et essayer de faire sentir de faire
entendre ce qui se passe une petite
partie de ce qui se passe avec d'autres
moyens et si c'est les moyens de
vraiment delà de la poésie pour faire
ressentir aux gens quelque chose une
vraie émotion mais tous les jours quand
on s'intéresse à ça on se rend compte
qu'il ya des petites pièces du puzzle
qui viennent s'ajouter récemment il ya
eu une tribune dans le monde signée par
jean pierre filiu qui raconte comment
justement de syriens chercheur
universitaire vivant aux pays bas ont
réussi à rentrer en contact avec un
tortionnaire du régime et comment cette
personne a avoué parce que les deux
chercheurs en l'occurrence son
déguisés ou cachés sous des pseudonymes
cette personne a finalement avoué ce
qu'elle avait fait ce qu'elle avait
commis comme atrocités et c'est
absolument terrible mais toutes ces
choses on les découvre petit à petit et
c'est là qu'on voit et on peut faire un
parallèle avec ce qui se passe en
ukraine pour le moment c'est une guerre
de l'information
et c'est une manière de cacher des pans
entiers de l'histoire syrienne toutes
les atrocités commises par le régime de
bachar on en sait quelque chose mais on
est loin de connaître la vérité complète
et l'ampleur de ce qui s'est joué là bas
et des gens qui résistent bien sûr il y
en a énormément bien sûr et on en parle
peut continuer d'essayer d'en parler ici
qu'est ce que ça au fait de recevoir
autant d'honneur en ce moment c'est très
ironique parce que ce livre et on le
sent je crois dans la parole de mahmoud
elle-même quand je les écris moi j'étais
dans une période je ne souhaitais plus
forcément justement publier ses traits à
particulier de décrire en écrit
peut-être parfois aussi pour se cacher
un peu et puis une médiatisation qui
arrive je voudrais commencer en 2015
donc ouais j'ai commencé et le livre a
dormi deux ans d'ailleurs j'ai terminé
de l'écrire et n'ayant plus forcément
envie de publier à cette époque là il a
dormi dans un tiroir et c'est ma
compagne qui m'a dit un jour mais tu as
écrit un texte sur la sur la syrie
qu'est ce qu'il est devenu et je lui ai
dit je lui ai lu le premier chapitre et
elle m'a dit peut-être qu'il serait
temps d'essayer d'en faire quelque chose
de le publier et ce qui est très
ironique c'est que parfois quand on ne
veut pas faire quelque chose
et ce quelque chose concret malgré tout
touche les gens et ça j'en suis j'en
suis extrêmement ravi honoré mercier
ballon on est ravi et honoré de vous
avoir reçu antoine wauters pour parler
de ce livre donc mahmoud de la montée
des eaux ce taux des ide aux éditions
verdier merci beaucoup un livre qui
poursuit sa vie et qui continue à
recevoir des des prix près d'un mois
après sa sortie au plaisir de vous
retrouver un coup ici est